dark skies is brought to us by the
Director of Legion and priest dark skies
is the trailer that you probably saw and
laughed more during than any comedy
trailer of this or the previous year
lots of funny moments in that trailer so
going into this movie I wasn't terribly
optimistic at Starr's Keri Russell and
some guy I don't know who he is
basically it's a story of this family
that lived in this house and I got these
kids and they're having some domestic
problems their jobs aren't going too
well they're having a lot of fights the
kids are having weird experiences at
night birds are flying into the house
all these weird things are happening
they're hearing noises and odd strange
sounds and kids are getting stuff like
written on their bodies and they don't
know what's going on they begin to
suspect aliens now I really like alien
stuff I love the x-files I love the
movie science I love Close Encounters of
the Third Kind I love alien movies in
which they're able to in realistic ways
depict a suspenseful or frightening
alien encounter of some kind where it
doesn't get over the top and you
actually start to believe it and it
seems real and I will say this movie is
not as bad as it looked I will say that
is it good not really but it is not
quite as bad as that I thought it was
going to be it does have some
suspenseful scenes it has some good
tension in there at times and Carey
rustling bad in the movie she was giving
a lot to her role I could tell she was
trying to in some way lend some credence
to this movie and actually give it some
believability and she did a pretty good
job in this movie her husband I'm not
exactly sure the actor's name
he was really overly serious in this
movie and I mean to the point where like
some scenes you're like dude stop
bulging your eyes out so much like his
kid was talking to me it was just like I
was like dude you know tone it down a
little bit now the problem with this
movie is it's so silly it unfortunately
starts to stray into the more comedic
category at times the way the script is
written the dialogue between the
characters and everything it just comes
off so forced and unreal and silly and
it starts to get cheese
and so when the scares happen it gets a
little funny because you aren't that
invested in these people because the
description isn't that up to par with
the directing and it's written and
directed by the same guy he's definitely
a better director than he has writer
because like I will honestly say there
are legitimate scenes in this film that
are scary and not always just because of
extremely loud music which unfortunately
does happen quite often in this movie
more often I was just on edge the
thought of a loud boom unsettling me
because the freaking sound effects are
just so like ear piercing lis loud
you're obviously going to be startled by
quiet and then all of a sudden just
blood is in your face it's not I mean
it's like it's not scary there are a few
scenes that win this movie where I felt
legitimate tension but for the most part
as the movie progresses
I started to see that it was really just
a giant copy off of a lot of better
movies there are humongous portions in
this movie that are just a blatant
ripoff of signs I mean they board up
their house they have like a big Last
Supper they're telling stories about
when they were young and trying to make
the kids laugh just like in signs and
you see little shadows through the
board's and I was like this is really
copying off of signs like a lot don't
mess with my signs man that movie
inspired me a lot I understand if you
don't like signs as much as I do that
movie just came at the right time for me
and it was the first movie I saw that
truly got me into the idea of filmmaking
and film criticism actually so I owe a
lot to signs which is why I have a
poster for it right there so when I see
a movie that kind of blatantly copies
off of it in a lot of ways it's kind of
offensive to me it also copies a bit off
Close Encounters of the Third Kind and
we are not the x-files and I know that
it's difficult to tell an alien invasion
tale of this type like a family
abduction tale without going for all the
tropes that the x-files has covered a
thousand times over see I'm a huge
x-files fan as well if you can't tell
that's the poster from molars office I
want to believe and so when I see these
movies I can recognize like obviously
these people were inspired by these
previous films or TV series it just
comes off so not real and Hollywood eyes
dand fake and set up in this nice glossy
production and you just don't really get
that real
sense that movies like Close Encounters
or signs with the television show The X
Files gave also when these things
eventually do show up the CGI is awful
it's not good and you can just really
tell that it is fake this is the kind of
scary movie word like there's all these
weird sound effects and noises that pop
up in facial expressions and stuff like
the wife is walking up and the husband
just goes ah it's like just like that
dark skies is a silly cheesy film that
actually does have a few scary scenes
that were legitimately disturbing a good
central performance but terrible
dialogue really and just it just gets
really over the top and the CGI just
doesn't work and you can tell that it's
copying off of other things that were
much better so for that reason I'm going
to give dark skies a C thanks a lot for
watching guys and as always if you like
this then you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
Oh